We've tried a few different
varieties of melting down metal,
and pouring it into clear ice.
This time, we've got a bunch of lead,
and we want to see if
it has a similar reaction
to what we've seen before,
or if we'll get something new.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
Here's the basic idea.
We picked up a whole
lot of lead fishing sinkers
from a local super center.
We're gonna throw them down our crucible,
and melt those suckers down.
And while they're melting,
we'll drill a hole about 60 percent
of the way through our block of clear ice,
mix the two together,
and see if we can get them to explode.
[Music]
Having the lead rest on
top of the block of ice
is pretty fun.
The heat from the lead gets
transferred down into the ice,
and it just carves a funny
texture over the whole thing.
[Music]
Lead melts at a much lower temperature
than the other metals we've tried,
so I suspect this
will go quite a bit faster.
[Music]
Here we go.
In 3, 2, 1...
Holy cra—
I love when it explodes.
Oh, that was intense.
That was a big explosion.
Wow!
Shattered that block of ice.
Just tore it apart.
Popped this off so
it stops lighting on fire.
Let's look at the damage from this one.
Oh, our poor GoPro.
Got exploded off the shelf.
This is the same GoPro
that got brass on it,
molten brass,
from when we tested molten brass in ice.
You can still see some of the
brasses still embedded in the GoPro,
still stuck there,
but still counting
despite a foreign body,
and having just been
blown backwards off the table.
I don't know what makes the difference.
It seemed like when we did aluminum,
and it exploded,
we had more small pieces,
like it shattered.
Whereas the lead, definitely
tore the block of ice into pieces—
I mean, we have a good spread.
We've got ice like
6-8 feet away from the table,
and then just in lots of big piece,
but it's in mostly big pieces.
There's not tons of tiny little shards,
and that could be that
the ice was colder
when we did it with the aluminum.
It was cold in the dome,
and so the ice stayed really cold.
Whereas today,
it's fairly warm in the dome,
and so, maybe,
the ice wasn't as cold.
I know what you're
thinking, ice is ice.
It's freezing cold.
But when we've done this before,
it was actually like
10-15 degrees Fahrenheit
here in the dome.
So, it really was keeping it colder
than the freezing temperature of ice.
Wow!
Where did all the metal go?
Gonna have to watch that on slow mo.
I think it probably
just got blown into the air,
or something like that, scattered,
which is why I was
60 feet away outside the Dome.
It's mostly gone.
Like there's little bits on the table,
here and there,
but that Crucible was full.
Had a tiny bit left
in it when I took it out.
Poured it out.
We just have molten,
formally molten metal,
strewn about on
the ground of the Dome in here.
We've had a lot of molten metal in here.
We've seen this effect before.
We have this sort of
cone pyramid-shaped leftover.
This is where I drilled
using the spade bit
down into the ice,
and it broke down away from that.
But you can still see the point
right where the drill bit was.
Here's what remains of our
giant block of clear ice.
It's pretty well been smashed into pieces.
It's weird that it completely
destroyed the bottom one.
Here is all of the lead
that I was able to find,
just scattered around the table,
and when I poured some out of the crucible
trying to get it out of our metal cup,
I'd say we have
a fair amount of it here,
but we're still probably missing it
at least 30 to 40 percent of it.
So, some of that must have just
been scattered when the ice exploded.
My only explanation.
So, lead in a block of ice
exploded the ice.
Salt?
We got to explode a block of ice.
Aluminum?
We got to explode block of ice.
Copper and brass both didn't explode.
We had them cast somewhat
down in the ice.
We had them geyser up out of the ice, somewhat,
and those were both really
cool to watch.
But they weren't the explosion
that happens from the aluminum, the lead.
Now the aluminum and led both
melt at much lower temperatures
than brass and copper.
So, maybe there's something there.
I'm still guessing it has to do with
the specific heat of each material
that we try it with.
Maybe more testing is still an order.
Guys, there's still more for you to see.
That little box up at the top
will transport you directly to our last video.
The box in the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe to the channel,
so, you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.